[Music]
i was out here all alone once
bruce made me go under the forest by
myself for the first time
i had no idea what was out there he was
just a boy
those were the lessons that he taught
you
bruce was a psychopath using fear to
control everyone
you need to make sure that this doesn't
happen to someone else
[Music]
that man's ally was found dead tonight
it's over for me be a better batman
barbara welcome back to gotham dick
batman's gone gotham
it's mine now we're investigating this
new red hood case
who's he said be a better batman and
titans got this
you know how crazy that is right trying
to step into your father's shoes
i do commissioner gordon
whole world is turned upside down i
think i'm losing my mind
if you're gonna dump i'm gonna hawk
we need to stop it for cases like these
we've been using a consultant
scarecrow dr crane
dick grayson's red hood is a biblical
brother
the king moves stealthily in the shadows
while the ponds are sent to the teeth of
destruction
it's just his opening move i come from
you come after family
we show no mercy
[Music]
you